hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ihr seht ich stehe endlich
in meiner neuen küche wir haben es
geschafft dass küchen die küchenbauer
waren da haben die küche installiert
aber meine küche ist leider nicht fertig
wie man auch sehen kann
hier oben will überall noch die lampen
und statt hinten fehlt noch meine
rückwand da kommt ein holz rückwand hin
so wie auch unser boten zeigt mal kurz
da kommt auch so eine eiche seine reiche
holz rückwand hin und es ist nur ein
bisschen arbeit was wir haben ich habe
auch erst gestern angefangen meine küche
einzuräumen dafür noch ganz viele
schränke leer und hinter der kamera
stehen ganz viele kartons herum
aber das mache ich jetzt einfach alles
mit der zeit und ich habe gedacht ich
stets endlich wieder in der küche weil
eben kühlen studie was zwar ganz schön
aber mir gefällt einfach zu hause viel
besser weil das einfach meine umgebung
ist und mein material mein werkzeug und
ich möchte jetzt endlich rezepte machen
für euch und zwar habe ich mir jetzt
gedacht dass ich ganz viele kleine
videos mache weil ich habe ganz viele
kleine grüne rezepte für euch und um
praktisch so ein ganzes grill menü
zusammenzustellen und heute fange ich
mit meinem allerletzten grill rezept an
das ist nämlich das rezept von meinem
papa und heute gibt es lange spiesse
jetzt denken wahrscheinlich viele
obgleich es keine nahm ich mag kein name
mir ist es viel zu stark aber dass ich
einfach so bei diesem gericht schmeckt
man es gar nicht raus das islamisch weil
es einfach durch die ganze würze und so
weiter verfeinert wird das ist einfach
dieser lamm geschmack weg ist ich mochte
früher auch kein baum habe das nie
gegessen wenn wir irgendwo essen war ich
habe immer gesagt ich es nicht
bis dann einfach mein papa ehemann
gesagt hat du das was wir seit jahren
essen diese lange spiesse des des islam
und ja dann habe ich mich eben mal
überwunden und gesagt okay dann mache
ich das jetzt einfach mal selber und
seitdem mag ich das auch sehr sogar viel
mehr als rindfleisch weil ich find das
lamm einfach viel zarter schmeckt und
schmeckt einfach besser und bei diesen
langen spiessen ist es so dass die ganz
kleinen gemacht werden und auf türkisch
wird man jetzt sagen loccum gewinn
das heißt einfach dass zu mini mini
kleine würfelchen sind und die sind so
lecker das schmeckt wirklich wie bonbons
vom spieß und
zeige ich jetzt einfach mal meine
zutaten ich habe ganz viele gewürze
benutzt ihr müsst natürlich nicht alle
benutzen aber ich sage euch einfach was
die wichtigsten gewürze sind und wie man
die samen spießer zubereitet auf den
ersten blick sieht es jetzt ganz viel
aus aber im prinzip habt ihr das alles
zu hause oder bekommt es auch einfach in
einem supermarkt ich habe jetzt hier 15
kilogramm fleisch
das habe ich jetzt schon klein
geschnitten und ihr seht auch wie klein
ich das geschnitten habe also das sind
so etwa kleine würfelchen hier so 15
zentimeter und da habe ich einfach ein
halbes langen gekauft und habe den rest
eingefroren das ist jetzt einfach von
der schulter das fleisch und ihr seht
auch das darf nicht zu mager sein sonst
verbrennen euch die spieße zu schnell
ich habe hier drei esslöffel tomatenmark
könnte auch paprika markt nehmen drei
teelöffel salz 3 esslöffel paprikapulver
das ist jetzt es nicht schaffe also
edelsüß hier habe ich drei teelöffel
pfeffer habe ich frisch gemahlen 75
milliliter öl da hab ich jetzt
geschmacksneutrale öl also
sonnenblumenöl zum beispiel eine zitrone
kann auch ein bisschen mehr sein
hier habe ich ganz wichtig sechs
esslöffel thymian majoran oder oregano
und das ist es getrocknete und es gibt
im ganzen auch den super geschmack hier
habe ich drei teelöffel comen das ist
kreuzkümmel und das ist jetzt hier schon
gemahlen kommission auch wirklich und
hier habe ich drei esslöffel
pfefferminze die hatte ich letztes jahr
mit meiner mama zusammen getrocknet
können dann natürlich auch frische
nehmen aber hier sind die getrockneten
etwas besser und drei esslöffel
chilipulver dass ich das scharfe chili
pulver und natürlich trocken und fein
gemahlen dessen jetzt wirklich viele
gewürze aber ihr bekommt die meisten zum
beispiel in einem türkischen supermarkt
gerade dieses team ion also kopien
dieser kreuzkümmel gibt es dort wenn ihr
jetzt sagt ich mag kein kreuzkümmel ich
würde euch trotzdem empfehlen zu diesem
gedicht pop jetzt mal aus was schmeckt
jetzt nicht so heraus und wenn es dann
doch nicht mit können dass er beim
nächsten mal doch wieder weg lassen
und das werde jetzt einfach mit dem
fleisch vermengt ich ziehe jetzt dafür
meine handschuhe an weil ich einfach
heute ganz viel zu bereit und ich möchte
dass meine hände zu abstimmen
deswegen die handschuhe mein papa macht
immer ohne dann nehme ich jetzt erstmal
hier zehn jahren
die pfefferminze muss jetzt noch ein
bisschen reiben weil die im ganzen ist
einfach alle trockenen zutaten und das
vermisse ich jetzt einfach mal schön
einfach schön ein kneten und wenn ihr
das macht das riecht einfach so gut
diese ganzen gewürze und ich bin
eigentlich jemand del nicht zu sehr
würzt aber das land muss man wirklich
gut würzen das schmeckt einfach so gut
und es macht echt jeder also keiner
glaubt dass es lang spielte jetzt gebe
ich noch tomatenmark 1
auch mein öl und ich werde euch auf dem
blog einfach auch die 15 fache menge
aufschreiben also diese mit 15 kilo
lammfleisch
aber wenn ihr natürlich nicht so viele
personen seid dann nimmt er einfach ein
drittel davon mit 500 gramm dass sich
auch super zum herunterrechnen zitrone
die ich auch ganz ganz wichtig und dann
knetet es einfach richtig lange ein
das muss richtig schön mit den gewürzen
vermengt werden
und ich hatte das fleisch übrigens ganz
frisch gekauft habs klein geschnitten
und habe es dann eingefroren weil wir
dann noch zwei tage weg waren bei
freunden und jetzt habe ich einfach
gestern macht wieder in den kühlschrank
gelegt in einer schüssel hat es
aufgetaut und es geht dann sofort also
das ist wirklich klasse
und wenn ihr das ganz gut ein geknetet
hat muss das fleisch über nacht in den
kühlschrank damit diese ganzen erhoben
und gewürze auch einziehen kann
ich steckte es jetzt einfach mit einem
deckel ab da spiegelt klein
arbeitest du ein ganz toller deckel der
macht dann so eine kleine baku er bildet
ihr sohn marco und so gibt es jetzt
keine gerüche an meinen kühlschrank ab
und dann gebe ich das jetzt einfach über
nacht in den kühlschrank und west sind
am morgen zum aufspießen wieder
herausholen
bei uns war die lange spiesse mit einem
flipchart gegessen dann müsst ihr
natürlich nicht machen aber den empfehle
ich euch auf jeden fall dazu und dafür
braucht ihr diese zutaten
wir brauchen natürlich zwiebel hier habe
ich bereits vier stück geschält und
geschnitten und das ist auch so eine
kleine menge also ihr könnt natürlich so
viel machen wie ihr möchtet
ich habe hier einen halben bund
petersilie zwei zitronenöl natürlich
olivenöl und hier habe ich gewürze und
zwar ist es jetzt essig baum
geburtszimmer clijsters und es gibt es
im türkischen laden natürlich in dem
supermarkt hier habe ich jetzt etwa zwei
esslöffel davon ein teelöffel salz etwas
pfeffer also so eine prise pfeffer und
etwas chiliflocken das kann jetzt noch
sein dass ich den salat gleich noch mit
ein paar gewürze mehr auf pep muss und
etwas mehr pfeffer nehmen muss und etwas
mehr chili das kommt einfach darauf an
wie groß ihre zwiebeln sind und wie wird
sich jedes haben wollte es gibt jetzt
wahrscheinlich viele von euch die jetzt
zum ersten mal was über diese summe kern
über dieses essig gewürzt ich mache
natürlich nicht nur meine zwiebel verlag
damit zum bei sondern auch zum beispiel
meinen kartoffelsalat und es ist
wirklich so ein sehr vielseitiges
gewürgt und ihr dürft jetzt nicht denken
ich kaufe das jetzt und benutzt es dann
wirklich nur noch dafür sondern seid
einfach etwas kreativ also ich finde es
gewiss richtig super weiß nicht kennt
sollte das mal testen
es riecht eben nach essig also so sauer
es schmeckt auch säuerlich kostet so
etwa zwei euro so ein gläschen und das
könnte auch im salat benutzen als in
anderen salaten in wunden salaten
probiert einfach mal aus des
schwedischen gewährt das mag ich auch
sehr auch gerade im kartoffelsalat und
ja die zwiebeln halbjährig ist und
schneit sie dann in dünneren
diese zwiebeln müssen jetzt noch
gewaschen werden und zwar werde ich
jetzt etwas kaltes wasser rein geben und
die zwiebeln schön waschen das wasser
abgießen einfach damit diese schärfe
auch weg geht also ich vertrag die
zwiebeln so zum beispiel gar nicht und
dann schmeckt der salat auch viel milder
viel angenehmer und das mache ich aber
schön
dann könnte die zwiebeln einfach noch
abgießen abtropfen und wieder zurück
jetzt nehme ich einfach noch meine
petersilie und taktisch unfall
die gebe ich da jetzt auch mit rein
ganzen gewürze und natürlich
zitronensaft
noch etwas öl so etwa 2 3 esslöffel und
jetzt vermisse ich das einfach mit den
händen ich nehme jetzt immer gerne
handschuh weil ansonsten meine hände
immer so abbrennen von der zitronensäure
und von den ganzen gewürzen so ich gebe
da jetzt noch ein bisschen von dem essig
baum gewürze dazu bei uns muster immer
reichlich drin sein
es hat auch dann richtig tolle farbe das
ist übrigens auch das rezept von meinem
papa dann müsste einfach mal abschmecken
wie viel salz pfeffer und so weiter ihr
noch braucht einfach mal probieren
bisschen salz und an dieser perfekt mit
meinem papa so meinen salat ist fertig
ich habe auch schon peter gebacken also
fladenbrot das ist in einem anderen
video und hole ich noch mein lammfleisch
was ich gestern eingelegt habe und setze
auf spielt hier sind die lange spiesse
und ihr seht mal hier
das wollte ich mal zeigen der verschluss
guckt euch mal den deckel an letztes mal
ein vakuum erst mal wieder abregen also
eigentlich stadt deckel für diese
schüssel zu klein
aber ihr seht ja ich habe ihnen einfach
reingelegt hat natürlich den vorteil da
bleiben alle gerüchte drin mein
kühlschrank riecht nicht und ich brauch
nicht so viel folie als ich möchte
komplett kommen von frischhaltefolie
alufolien allen ich finde sich immer so
ein bisschen der verschwendung und klar
sind ja man muss immer alles in maßen so
ich möchte das jetzt einfach mal kurz
durch das fleisch kritisch in karls
macht jetzt wieder mit handschuhen damit
das jetzt
ich so auf meine hände abfärbt die hände
nicht riechen und nicht brennen und
spieß jetzt auch so holzspieße auf die
könnte jetzt vorher natürlich noch im
wasser einlegen damit sie nicht
verbrennen
aber mein mann kriegt es auch nicht dass
das verbrennen und die verbrennen auch
nicht als ich kenne viele dieses
einlegen
aber das braucht man gar nicht jetzt
werden die aufgespießt und da müsse
darauf achten dass er sie nicht zu eng
aufspießt also schön so immer mal wieder
eins mit fett zwischendrin mühselig
genug abstand
und dann drücken wir das einfach nicht
so dass es gleichmäßig ist dass da nix
raushängt und nichts verbrennen kann
wenn mein vater erklärt weil er ganz
stolz auf seine lang spielte so sollen
sie dann aussehen sind klein und wie man
hat es immer so wenn wir mit der familie
kennen da gibt es dann nicht nur ebenso
eineinhalb kilo spiel sondern gleich mal
elf kilo spieße wir sind ja eine große
familie
und dann macht mein privates fleisch
also der witz das sind alles und den tag
später dann alle um den tisch und spesen
alle die spieler auf das ist eigentlich
immer ganz lustig damit dem angeguckt
bei kann es am schnellsten am besten
aber schon immer der papa so ich würde
jetzt mal sagen mein mann liegt die
kamera weg wir schließen das zusammen
auf und dann wird gleich wieder an die
spitze kommen dann einfach auf den grill
dass ich bei uns übrigens tradition dass
man das mit der hand macht hat man
einfach so eine wasserschüssel
befeuchtet sich die hände und dann kann
es drauflegen und wänden und unternehmen
das macht mein papa immer zu mir
ausmachen
ich mach das service der papa gezeigt
hat
jetzt will ich die einfach nach und nach
und der grill ist wirklich ein bisschen
klein aber es ist okay und noch ein
kleiner tipp von uns
und zwar haben wir hier buchen holzkohle
das ist also nicht diese biokohle dies
ergibt diese buchenholz kohl hat nämlich
einen besseren brennwert und mit diesem
barbecue zeit kriegt man gar nicht diese
temperatur hin und schmeißt er fleisch
erst drauf wenn sich die weiße schicht
gebildet hat dann ist er genau dass die
temperatur erreicht ist und könnt ihr
euer fleisch tragen und grillen können
nicht warten und so sind sie dann fertig
aus also richtig schön aber nicht so
lange braten
ich bin ja auch gleich gebräunt ist aber
trifft es besser wo papa aber so sehen
auf jeden fall bringt die bereitschaft
macht zu sehen jetzt die fertigen
fleischspieße aus ich habe jetzt hier
meinen namen späße und trage ich noch
hühnchen spieße und diese nahm spitze
könnte jetzt mit dem zweiten pott essen
mit dem zwiebel salat wie ihr seht dann
nochmal unseren ganzen kritisch und ich
freue mich natürlich aufs nächste video
die anderen videos die verlinkt ich euch
alle die bekommt ihr alle als rezept und
dann wünsch euch ganz viel spaß freue
mich natürlich wenn ihr meine
grillrezepte auch mit anderen teilen und
wenn ihr meine bewertung geht und den
kommentator ist bis zum nächsten mal